a rhino is worth
more debt than alive worst case scenario
is that we're going to lose everything
the species is really on the brink
it enrages you right there so much
hard working and never give up they will
go there they will keep the rhinos and
they will get away with it
the last stand of the endangered black
rhino could be here
in namibia there are fewer than 6 000
left in the world and namibia has 90
of
rhino black them running across the
plains
usually with their tail up in the air
it's
uh that's africa
the country's also custodian to the
second largest white rhino population
so there's a big responsibility to
protect them from poachers
it's the morning milk run for annetta
oliver oops today you are different
today
switch around huh today you are
switching around
and her rhino orphans are waiting for
her tubs of sustenance
[Music]
she's hand reared these two from birth
determined to do her bit to save the
species from criminal gangs who
slaughter them for their horns
it enrages me it enrages me to take such
a
such a um a valuable
life which just for this piece of dust
i mean it's dust it's just it's just
nothing
and i feel for it they're 17 months old
and about to be weaned
but still babies playful and curious
about our team
yeah finished it's finished
there is
if you want to feel his mouth is soft
and soft but if you put your finger in
there you can feel how strong they are
because that
jeez that is how he rips off the grass
wow that's really hard yeah he's pulling
yeah
and it's that muscle is immensely strong
because that's how he's feeding
how it pulls off the grass
[Music]
she's been saving orphan rhinos for
nearly three decades
sleeping with them in her stable they
see her as their mother
and she nurses them to adulthood
it's your lucky you by the time they're
ready to be released into the wild like
cato and camshona
there's a unique bond
hmm
it's unbelievable to think that these
guys are still
babies they're huge and how much do they
weigh in it
probably 450 kilos 450 kilos each
that's the same as a mini caravan each
that's amazing
she runs the family farm and safari
business with her son
and they're focused on conservation
they believe legalizing the sale of
rhino horn is one way of saving the
species
currently worth more dead than alive
at this present moment what's the value
of that miner
what do you think zero
the value the legal value of that rhino
is zero
the illegal value of that rhino is
probably four kilogram horn 60 000 us a
kilo
about 240 000 us illegal value
we've lost so so many rhino
you know the the species is really on
the brink
that we just want to conserve every
single one
they're constantly fighting the war
against poachers
with no animal off
[Music]
feel so limits to be able to see that
fight because it only takes
a poacher to get lucky once for them to
die
look at this vast area of land that they
have to
try and secure
namibia's wildlife is the draw here
but coronavirus has punched a hole in
the tourism industry
halting so much travel
security companies are training teams to
take on the poachers
but their contracts are being slashed
right back as the safari lodges cut
costs
we are withdrawing from certain farms
because
of the of the financial impact
and and that leaves the rhinos up for
grabs i mean
and and we are seriously concerned about
the fact that
the poaching will pick up soon again and
because of the fact that the
the the anti-poaching units will step
down
the anti-poaching units are probably
doing the most important job on the
country's game reserves this is one
man's private army
against the criminal syndicates and this
is his first line of defense
namibia's largest stock of white rhinos
is kept on this sprawling farm
and every single one of them is precious
and heavily protected
their location is secret any details
could lead
criminals here and cost a rhino's life
you can see how easy it is for poachers
to get close to them
because we are definitely close enough
if we were a poacher to be able to shoot
that's why they go to such extraordinary
length to protect them
but keeping some of the world's
remaining white rhinos alive
is a heavy financial burden we are
actually
at the brink of going bankrupt um
we are really really struggling to pay
everything
we during corona time we had to let
unfortunately i had to let a few people
go
this shooting isn't to kill the rhino
but to keep it alive
it's being drugged so it can be
transported to safety
the mission here is to repopulate the
world with rhino
so it's 42.5 centimeters
and that's meant taking them out of
their african home and selling them
abroad
with many headed to america
[Applause]
they're also cutting off the horns of
some of the rhinos left behind
it makes them less attractive to
poachers and it will grow back
but the criminals who kill for the horn
know they can sell it on the black
market for millions
their mainly far east customers
mistakenly believe it's an aphrodisiac
and a medicine
the horns stored in bank vaults and
various security companies and
frequently moved around to avoid
detection
yeah that's quite a large amount
yeah this is approximately 15 16
kilograms um so we're talking about
times 80 000 us it's roughly 1.2 million
us dollars worth on the on the black
market of course
but he can't sell any of it it's illegal
he says right now it's only the poaching
gangs who are making money out of the
rhinos
goes to extraordinary lengths to protect
the rhinos on his farm
how effective do you think this whole
gyrocopter
is an anti-pigeon it's it's
i i i think that's our big um
weapon it's deterrent
from the air he can spot the animals
and keeps tabs on their movements
and he does this day and night
uh well our biggest fear is is that uh
the poachers the
that they're gonna get killed by by
rhino poachers for their arms
jacko's eyes in the sky help guide his
colleague juliet on the ground to where
the rhinos are yeah
she tracks down each rhino looking out
especially for those with carbs
and she logs them all she's named each
one of them
and knows them all by sight hi did we
scare you
i'm sorry calm down
calm down girls hi
hi sexy girls and there's another boy
hi princess calm down all right
all right good girls boys
the pandemic lockdown plus tougher
sentencing has led to a dramatic drop in
poaching numbers
but with restrictions lifting they're
fearing the worst here
poetry numbers has decreased but that
doesn't mean it's the wall's over
and i think coronavirus has just made it
go down a bit but
i think we're going to rock it up again
in a year or two's time when things go
back to normal
they're going to want to catch up for
what they've lost out on
so they're working hard to prepare for
that
and they feel the burden of
responsibility on all of them
we must keep on pushing we must just be
hard working and never give up of just
uh with this pandemic of coronavirus
that we must just
work on our best or do on our best just
to protect the rhinos
but right now there are just a few
standing between the rhinos and the
poachers
and so far the poachers seem to keep on
winning
the massive economic impact caused by
the pandemic
will also rebound on these creatures
who just can't seem to escape the threat
of being wiped out
alex crawford sky news namibia